hey remember last week i was talking
about the henderson symphony's holiday
jukebox concert well it was friday night
and it was a big success i had the honor
of narrating the snowman so as the
orchestra was playing and i was
narrating the animated movie was playing
on a screen over the orchestra and there
was a talented soloist check out julia
fleischer from coronado high school
[Music]
he fell in his pocket
and the scarf that father christmas had
given him
was
still there
it's a great story about the young man
who builds a snowman that comes to life
now as conductor jeff newman pointed out
it's you need to thank the volunteer
musicians from the henderson symphony a
lot of them have day jobs or school and
they still put in the time to make it
shine props to julia fleischer she told
me the snowman's been a favorite in her
family forever she was really pumped
about being able to sing in a
performance and all of coronado's
madrigals also had their own section
with the orchestra thanks to julie
williams the orchestra's director of
operations and also to the pinecrest
academy sloan canyon campus where chuck
mcguire made that beautiful auditorium
available you can follow the anderson
symphony at their website henderson
symphony.org